attention des enfants c'est parti si
l'écriture un texte d'hervé le tellier
intitulé la gymnastique des mots voilà
la version 2021 de la dictée d'ela au
collège marcel robbie de
saint-germain-en-laye une centaine
d'élèves de primaire se sont prêtés au
jeu un exercice en présence de benoît
carloni jeune homme de 30 ans atteint de
leucodystrophie venue avec ses parents
c'est une solidarité qui n'est pas
commune aujourd'hui c'est c'est super
pour benoît il a 30 ans bon maintenant
il ya d'autres enfants qui naissent avec
cette maladie et il faut trouver quelque
chose pour chaque nom sur la maladie
comédien et chanteur david ban s'est mué
en professeur des écoles lui qu'on peut
voir dans plus belle la vie ou la
comédie musicale 1789 les amants de la
bastille il est parrain de l'association
ela depuis 2015
j'essaie de faire en sorte que ce soit
un petit moment le partage que les
enfants s'en souviennent aussi il ya
aussi une partie des enfants qui ont qui
contribue à mettre en place cette dictée
donc je trouve que c'est bien c'est
courageux de leur part côté organisation
des élèves de 4e du collège marcelle
roux mobile décoration mise en place des
feuilles accueil des invités ils se
mobilisent à leur manière contre la
maladie
personne encore n'a trouvé de 2 par
exemple de médicaments pour soigner
cette maladie donc je trouve que c'est
bien de participer à cette association
je crois que c'est assez important de
participer à cette association parce que
il ya de l'argent qui récoltait dans
cette association et ça aide aux
personnes qui sont handicapés à cause de
cette maladie
la matinée solidaire c'est fini sur une
note de musique
encore plus fort un extrait du dernier
album de david barnes